salut aujourd'hui c'est la cinquième
vidéo sur les rubik's cube et on touche
le bout en fait on à l'avant dernière
étape pour que vous puissiez résoudre un
rubik's cube en moins de deux minutes
avec seulement cinq formules et on va
apprendre la cinquième formule est
aujourd'hui le premier jour on a vu
comment faire la première phase avec la
première couronne en une seule fois le
deuxième jour on a vu comment faire la
deuxième couronne le troisième jour
comment faire la croix le quatrième jour
dont qui hier comment faire correspondre
les cubes du centre avec la deuxième
couronne aujourd'hui c'est une opération
un petit peu délicate à un petit peu
complexe on va se la voir à pas se
mentir il faut qu'on place les coins aux
endroits correspondants il faut qu'on
place les coins de telle sorte à ce que
les trois faces de ces coins
correspondent aux trois face à laquelle
ils sont associés
si on regarde sur ce coin là on a jaune
orange vert alors que ça devrait être
jaune rouge bleu ici c'est bleu jaune
rouge ça devrait être jaune vert rouge
et pour celui ci ça match on a le bleu
qui va être ici le orange qui va être là
et le jaune qui va être là oui il est
pas positionnés dans le bon sens mais ça
ce sera le sujet de la vidéo demain pour
l'instant on veut juste que le coin soit
au bon endroit c'est tout et comme de la
vidéo d'hier la formule qu'on va
apprendre aujourd'hui va nous permettre
de faire un saut de mouton un petit peu
entre les coins un des coins de rester
fixe et tous vont bouger d'un cran vers
la droite en sautant celui qui est fixe
pour le premier c'est pas très clair
c'est à dire que si je me positionne
comme ça celui ci restera fixe celui ci
passera là lui passera ici et lui
passera ici comme il hier si vous
choisissez pas le bon coup en fixe est
pas grave il suffira devrait appliquer
la formule une deux ou trois fois grand
maximum pour moi je vous la vous c'est
la formule la plus compliquée à retenir
parce que j'arrive pas à lui trouver une
logique particulière j'ai pas de moyens
mnémotechniques de m'en rappeler donc je
vais d'abord a pris réellement parker et
après je me la suis mis dans les doigts
d'un petit peu comme ceux qui jouent
d'un instrument de musique c'est
peut-être votre cas des fois on connaît
plus la partition de tête on n'est plus
capable de l'expliquer par contre on
sait prendre la guitare et le faire ou
prendre le piano et le faire le corps a
enregistré l'information à enregistrer
les mouvements plus on pratique et plus
ça devient facile
la formule c'est gauche-droite inversée
au gauche inversé ou inversée droite ou
gauche au inversée gauche inversée et je
l'écris comme chaque jour aussi dans le
descriptif de la vidéo je passe de
l'autre côté
l'écran pour vous faire voir après avoir
observé moncube je vois que si je mets
bien ce coin là où il va c'est à dire
avec du orange du bleu du jaune comme
les trois du coin celui-ci vert jaune
orange ira ici vert jaune orange on est
bon celui ci ira là le vert rouge jaune
vert rouge jaune ça correspond bien aux
faces et celui ci ira ici on est bons
endroits qu'il va rester fixe ce sera
celui ci donc je le place en haut à
gauche par rapport à moi au plus éloigné
de moi et au plus sur la gauche juste là
j'applique la formule et j'essaie d'y
trouver un peu de logique gauche et
droite inverser ça veut dire que la
gauche avance vers moi et la droite
également aux gauche envers c'est donc
au dans le bon sens gauche inversée et
ensuite au inversée et droite il me
reste plus qu'à faire ou gauche ou
inverser gauche inversée au gauche au
inversée gauche inversés et c'est
terminé et si on vérifie les coins sont
bien positionné par rapport aux faces
alors pas forcément bien dans le bon
sens comme celui ci ça c'est un hasard
mais ils sont tous bien à leur bonne
place peut-être vous n'y voyez pas une
grande difficulté moi en tout cas c'est
l'endroit qui m'avait posé un petit peu
problème
du coup on s'arrête là pour aujourd'hui
je pense que juste cette formule mérite
une vidéo une journée complète pour
assimiler
maintenant que les coins sont à leur
place il va juste à nous restait à les
mettre dans le bon sens à bien les
positionner et ça ça va être grâce et
une formule que vous connaissez déjà on
verra comment faire avec demain et ce
rubik's cube sera enfin résolu
entraînez-vous bien et rendez vous
demain à 17 heures pour le prochain
mentale vlog ciao
nous